cedex 15 cents à 75 300 paris brûle mais
cela dit je crois bien que garcimore
tentent d'entrer désespérément depuis
quelques instants
mais il nous nous interrompre parce
qu'il est certain que 2 millions de
centimes ça intimide fait un timide tout
ça oui bonjour madame vous savez pas vu
alors absolument ya longtemps que mag
est pas encore il ya vous n'aviez pas
joué le tour mais j'aimerais bien avant
que mon juillet à que nous raconter un
petit peu comment s'est passé ce voyage
en italie des années à venir
dites moi il était d'abord noailles et à
rome est la bienvenue mais quand même il
se doit puisque jamais donné beaucoup
parlé de venise
je suis allé tout décontracté en voiture
bien et quand je suis arrivé là-bas il
ya pas eu de chance parce qu'il promet
il y avait un orage
il ya beaucoup d'eau qu'ils tombent
alors c'est grave parce que trop démunis
bon il peut mais quand j'ai vu tout le
monde embarque j'avais cru qu avait
décidé une dation appelle un taxi
taquilla une barre qui est venue alors
il y avait passé l'été ici peut-être des
carabinieri la police ils sont pas trop
fort la protection civile le drôme
meilleur gagne vous l'êtes a fait mener
en bateau en gondole qu'au bon après
c'est allé vite dépassé 1 semaine avant
de visiter les pyramides ils
raconteraient quelqu'un qui m'a enfin
c'est pas une petite sacra conseil
m'expliquer et tous les maux mille et
une tension alors que vous m'expliquer
ça je vais cultive alors on prend jamais
beaucoup alors il m'avait dit que 4000
ans avant jésus-christ 5 milan quand
quelqu'un mourait il ferme humain à
l'eau après le metteur en scène charles
koffi est comme ça c'est insupportable
qui s'assoira qui m'ont mis ya rien là
c'est le petit moment alors il m'avait
dit que ces gens là cette époque là
comme on y croyait que la vraie vie ça
commençait à près d'un mois mais qui
serait ensuite pena qui s'interdit
arrive c'est du régime
les yogis morace était tellement léger
qui flottait dans l'air et tous il y
aurait pourtant il flotte pousse pousse
le must est encore quelque chose lâche t
il alors et il m'avait dit ça mais ce
qui m'avait si je vous ai pas dit c'est
quoi
non ce qui me fait vraiment rigoler
c'est qu'après il m'a dit bon au bout de
quelques temps la famille allez voici le
monial et bien qu'on est allé au bout de
quelques temps alors ils les maquillent
qu'on arrivera le mois malgré qu'ils
étaient embaumés tout il trouvait plus
parce qu'ils avaient ils avaient disparu
là je vais parce qu'on est un bon mètre
les restes du salut au moment où
l'italie comme méfait avant dé meaux
kitten me l'avez vous fait un tout qui
m'a studio parce que des fois y'a des
taux qui masse des taux qui masquent pas
maîtrisé dans le château qui marche
toujours pas le voir
evidémment et me sens bien à vrai dire
qu'il a bien marché il me semble qu'ils
aient déjà fait les taux de gouvenain
non non non ça c'en est trop pour vous
savez tous les gobelets c'est un talkie
mastur février une toque et matthew
[Rires]
cammas toujours écouter vraiment jeudi
regard sinon on vous fait un retour en
force et un aujourd'hui c'est à dire
qu'il se dirige vers pierre lannes ont
très nettement
oui
guy a il va prendre son temps
non non on va le laisser prendre le
temps de façon nous sommes là jusqu'à 18
heures non mais morale à l'image pas
appelé c'est pas terminé il on regarde
d'autres en corner bien vous surveiller
tous à des nuances à 20
[Musique]